what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we're going to watch the
Guardians of the Galaxy the holiday
special today John you're not koi how
are you I'm great Greg it's one minute
five minute three minutes and stuff how
are you doing great coy already watched
this and I said it would be a lie if you
were here
wanted to go to a theater where James
Gunn was there
anyway uh guys leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated also uh subscribe
click the notification Bell to get
notified when we got a reaction up here
in the channel that you might enjoy Also
full length Reaction watch alongs where
you sync up with your own copy for
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page and we also
cover a bunch of stuff over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watchalongs included special thank you
to all who have shown your support over
there trust me we've been dealing with
some BS copyright stuff lately so your
support means the world let's get to it
[Music]
settling
on sale
Ah that's cool you guys
is that animated that's animated
animated yeah that's like 2D this one
looks good
what in the fires of all guards I think
you doing hey Captain we're just uh have
you ever heard of Christmas what
where everybody gets presents for each
other
so Peyton Cracklin made this tree and we
got gifts for everyone it was Pete's
idea
it's more like a sign of appreciation
that sounds more like sediment boy that
may be okay for you mushy Types on
terror but out here in the cold rigors
of space is what'll get you killed and
you you ought to know better
tisk tisk if it ain't on here before I
get back you both going to be cleaning
the latrines for the rest of the damn
year but that's Jeff's favorite job
you're talking back now craglin no
oh dude
ah dude hey Christmas
buddy there's something there we need to
uncover I like how the animation was
like an old school Christmas movie yeah
right now on Earth it's almost Christmas
time so yeah it kind of brings back some
memories you only got a point ever since
buying nowhere from The Collector we
don't have time for trivialities like
Christmas bought nowhere from The
Collector that was such a heartbreaking
story
I know stories where everybody lives
what use is telekinesis if you can't
even aim concentrate you stupid mutton
what I refuse to do any more work while
you demean me
so cute so glad they got a real dog yes
out on the third planet closest to the
Sun there's a special celebration and it
sounds quite fun a jolly old fellow
brings toys to everyone on a holiday
they call Christmas
that's great it's beautiful
we're busy is this is this a long song
nice
picking locks no if you don't
get out he will put dung in your socks
that is not part of the lore no no coal
is not poop
it's reducing
I have a flame thrower
nice
[Laughter]
Santa's got to be rocking some infinity
stone energy
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is gonna get a lot of play this
holiday season
dog
and hold it up that deer lit up that
deer
Christmas is but Christmas Time Is Here
know what Christmas is but Christmas
Time Is Here this is catchy yeah
we need more in-universe musicals
I feel like I should do something why
because of you know my
that you ate the entire bowl of dog nuts
in the commissary my
up they're your cool sister
you should just tell people the truth
Our Father oh my God
maybe if we gave Peter a really
wonderful Christmas gift it would make
him happy well we could give him those
arguments because if you ate them all
yes ma'am over the years school has
talked about one person more than any
other a legendary hero who has saved
countless lives we could give him the
quilt as a present
let's do this let's bag of some bacon
hey honey hey baby
I can't wait for you guys to get back
from New York I would love if that
wasn't actually Kyra Cedric's voice I
hope they stay together otherwise this
will not age well
oh
rocks why are they staring
you put the cloaking device on like you
said you did right yes
if you keep the [ __ ] perfectly still
you'll be invisible
so we'll go down into the City and ask
people where giving bacon is I think
Kevin Bacon is the leader of the world
are just in most people
[Laughter]
in some ways we're all six degrees
separate from him
yeah we could probably go out and find
him this is where all the Marvel
premieres are yeah we're just off screen
left
this is for Iron Man 3 took place
oh no
hi oh yes
I'm sorry yes
I've got a picture with a God of War
out now he would be a good Kratos
[Music]
oh no Drex
laughs
okay King goes
oh snap now you can make this a real
restaurant this is one of my favorite
Saturday night Hangouts box
give us your finest libations
have you seen Kenny where why would I
know what Kevin Bacon is like flula
my thoughts exactly
foreign
[Laughter]
s of people on this planet
we don't even know what Kevin Bacon
looks like
you want to know where Kevin Bacon lives
it's hard Maps classic
move faster
do they meet all those people off screen
yes
for the legend Dairy Kevin Bacon we're
looking for the legendary Kevin Bacon
sorry guys
I can't help you
hello
hello
do you think you can toss me over the
gate if you
godspeed
Drax got hops beautiful
it's graceful probably could just
carried her over the gate yeah this is
not cool this is private property now
kindly put down my elf and my candy cane
and go I'm calling the police right now
oh yeah
you're coming with us as a Christmas
present
there's two I don't know what they are
people are people costumes
why would you go upstairs
with The High Ground
oh
my God
that's great wow
bacon got the Hops as well
I left my little funny man back in the
house what well how is it fair you get
to keep it and I don't because I I was
responsible and held on to it
[Laughter]
Tom Cruise run it
you gotta get these things away from me
hands above your head stop
tickle it in
my pants
oh my oh wow
damn Madness gets to kick some ass
[Music]
sleep
kick names and Take ass
[Applause]
whoa yeah
you can't just kill people
we are just taking the legendary hero
Kevin Bacon to give him as a present to
our friend who is sad about Christmas
okay here
oh I really wanted this but
or even now
we would love to come with us
hey
where are we going first there
clueless
wow they had they they got everything
there assaulted police officers left a
real grinches when you had a small town
by dancing like an idiot well that
wasn't me that was a character that I
played red McCormick in the movie
Footloose what
what about when you fought and defeated
this super strong masked killer Jason
Voorhees in the world
he's never actually
repugned it oh no profession I'm you
don't get to live just one life you get
to live so many lives we got quill the
worst gift ever a disgusting
Kevin Bacon you have to pretend you're
an actual hero or else Christmas is
doomed
fly me mate I can't wait to storm them
Nazis on the beach
no just your regular voice oh okay yeah
sure fine uh hello I'm the Batman
and I mean Hello I'm Bruce Wayne oh this
is Bruce Wayne this is so better
James Gunn DC
damn group should join the high school
football team
laughs
Smashing Pumpkins
oh that's gorgeous it's like Christmas
Blade Runner
oh
that is gorgeous I would love to visit
that get on at Disneyland yeah
Bob Iger get to it
[Music]
Eric they dropped bacon back off nah
he's got to be around here somewhere
he's gonna like pop gotta have a dance
off
damn sometimes looks like a guy in a
suit he really does yeah that's crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
you must be Pete Merry Christmas what'd
you do what what did you do we got you
Kevin Bacon as a present you got me a
human being
Christmas
[Music]
it's Christmas trafficking Mr bacon I am
so sorry this is really embarrassing I
know you're worried sick and your family
is too we're gonna get you back
don't run you're not gonna run
[Music]
go get Kevin Bacon
it's only because you mean a great deal
to Pete that they've done it you saved a
town for dancing
and once Pete
saved the whole galaxy with dancing for
real now he might just be the greatest
hero alive
hey aside from all the other Ventures
yeah
man in these dopes they was just hoping
you'd bring the joy of Christmas back
into his heart is all
oh you got a doctor who phone over here
yeah no I'm I'm just with some
friends would it be okay if I'm just a
little bit late
oh Kevin Bacon you sweet son of a crispy
bacon [ __ ]
son of a Christmas [ __ ]
[Music]
yes uh
bacon Bros in space so much merch to be
made for this one holiday special
so it was a Walkman
God those effects are like still
mind-blowing my game boy it's my old
Game Boy
insane facts man I wonder if they aimed
for like make it look like a suit
[Music]
that's fantastic
you too
[Music]
go nebula pop it lock it
oh I got the funny man
Ah that's cool
how did you know how to recreate that
so much merch to be made
yeah I guess your Etsy store going
oh he's got a star in his fin
[Music]
where's the Silver Surfer
I love you Kevin Bacon hey I'll see you
at Easter
oh yeah Easter special let's do it
Kragen told us the story about how he
owned a ruined Christmas
so we wanted to save it for you
I'm not sure craglin knows how that
story ended
yondu liked Christmas after all
I'm Rudolph the red news reindeer y'all
he got
Peter got that for him
from yondu
uh
that is the coolest present I guess I
just wanted to do something special for
you what
your father Peter he is my father too
which does that make you my sister
oh
[Music]
mantis
that's the greatest Christmas gift
that's really touching
[Music]
it's a Christmas miracle
I put down
[Music]
Rankin and bass presents Guardians of
the Galaxy
that's nice
when's the awesome Christmas mix
dropping
what's the post-credit scene
it's Adam Warlock Mark Hamill the high
evolutionary
it's Val Kevin Bacon from Hollow Man
that's that's the movie we need to bring
back into the public eye bring his
character from X-Men in here you can
watch this every year but how does it
tie into the rest of phase four in this
startup phase five well it does I mean I
imagine some of this information will
actually be quite pivotal leading into
Guardians three there are some pretty
important pieces of information like
what how they bought nowhere
name three things Cosmo because I'm
about to wonder out loud if any of those
shots were a guy in a suit I'm just
gonna assume there were no shots of any
guy in a crude suit it's gonna assume it
was all great CG yeah it was interesting
how they did that
[Music]
Jesus again
[Music]
we gotta have another special
confirmed
the Guardians will return next crisp
that was a really delightful special
yeah warmed my cockles
that's a real thing that's innocuous
that people say
it's an innocuous phrase and I'm not
even because I had warmed my soul
I'll allow it
oh
I will disambiguate it
uh yeah that was that was really
enjoyable I like how it actually leaned
into you know when you compare it to
something like werewolf by night which
felt like a a mini movie this actually
felt like a TV special but in the most
complimentary ways like you grew up on
like more Christmas specials than I did
um you know I didn't really grow up on
them but I've been introduced to them a
little bit later my fiance uh has shown
me like several so uh it didn't really
go up on them so like watching this I'm
like oh this leans into being like a
Christmas TV special and it really sets
the stage for that with its animated
format the way it's bookended with it
I'm like oh that's really cool how they
chose that specific stuff not like the
what if computer animation but the the
real 2D hand-drawn animation and it
feels like from an earlier era which I
thought was great but even the way he
framed it you know like it's not the way
it's shot is not shot like widescreen in
the way how he does like the films you
know this has more of a like the
standard TV format the dimensions of it
is what I'm talking about so I and just
like the overall Vibe of it it does like
when you hear the word
Christmas special holiday special TV
special that word special it it does
really accentuate that I think when
watching this so I thought it was great
um yeah it was just like really funny
and charming and the best mantis we've
gotten thus far yeah and I mean it's
it's a testament I think to the idea
that sometimes it's good to have
especially looking at this looking at
werewolf by night
I really hope they keep doing these
kinds of specials you know regardless of
holiday or whatever because it does give
you a nice opportunity to really focus
in on something and make something that
you know has its own type of impact and
especially for something like this I
thought that they managed to do
something yeah is quite of the Guardians
of the Galaxy quite of the Marvel
Universe but it is scaled in a really
nice way to match like the classic
tenets of the themes of a Christmas or a
holiday special you know the idea of
they don't like have to literally save
Santa from Peril or something like that
like Kiss has done in the past but you
know like in a way they do save
Christmas and they do sort of have to
learn what the meaning of Christmas
actually is uh without it feeling you
know super wrote or like it's just
playing that one beat either like this
felt like a really well proportioned
interlude you know yeah yeah I do like I
I think it also there there's one thing
I did find myself Desiring from it
um which I'll get into in a little bit
that I was like ah you know if they if
they if they if this was just a little
bit more enhanced I think it would have
hit it that much more in the end and
I'll go into that in a bit but I want to
stay on top of the things that I thought
really did Excel because the things with
Drax and mantis I thought
um helped complement
one of my I'm I'm part of the camp
that's not a big fan of Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2. I'm I'm I've seen it twice
and both times I've seen it I I just
that one just was weird for me because
Guardians one is one of my top Marvel
movies and um James Gunn in general is
like one of my favorites but Guardians 2
just doesn't quite mesh with me
and only one of the aspects of it that I
wasn't a big fan of was like the the
comedy elements of what Drax got
resorted to and Jackson mantis and even
though there were some really funny
parts but for the most part I just
didn't really find it that funny and
then here I actually think it makes that
in retrospect feel better even like
their their comedy bits in Infinity War
the way they play off each other like
this got to take Center Stage for the
most part amongst the characters that's
the one that gotta take Center Stage you
know you've had the I am Groot special
group is usually a scene sealer whatever
groots in a scene even here when grits
on screen he can't help but like be an
awe or admirer take your eyes out you
can't take your eyes off of him uh
Star-Lord obviously the main star of the
Guardians of the Galaxy and uh nebula's
had a lot of her own important
storylines so this was the chance to
really let the the duo of draxen and
mantis but especially mantis uh really
shining I thought that was cleverly done
and this really did feel like a
Christmas
um event you know I thought they really
leaned into that well because
you know as people who watch Doctor Who
whenever a lot of times it becomes a
debate of like it's a Christmas special
really we were to just like come out on
Christmas day and you make sure someone
mentions Christmas so it's technically
but it doesn't really feel like
Christmas yeah that's something that
really mattered to me watching this was
I wanted it to feel like Christmas and
uh Kevin Bacon I thought did a really
fun job too it looked like he was having
a genuine blast while making this and he
got a lot of uh fun little jokes he
gotta have in here as well and I like
how he the way he he comes around
because it's all fits within the tone of
it all yeah you know like his
performance had the right tone and
everyone was on the right pitch of the
kind of tone this short this uh mini
movie essentially is so when he like
does come around to wanting to be of
service on Christmas to give him a good
Christmas Day I thought was great the
part that I felt really uh I wanted more
of was not was leaning into star-lord's
emotion
um because it was is so much about
cheering him up and they did have the
thing about him being sad about Gamora
not being there and I thought of they've
leaned a little bit more into that
before the adventure really took off or
whenever or if they cut to it in between
while Drax and and mantis are out on
Earth having an adventure and then you
see that yeah like you know Christmas is
I think it was to be a very relatable
thing uh that people feel lonely around
the holidays
and you know Star-Lord without having
Gamora around it you know I thought like
okay if we lean a little bit more into
that that way when the Christmas stuff
does happen at the end and he is so
affected that like this really did cheer
him up but for the most part I felt like
while Chris Pratt had a few funny
moments and I loved his final scene with
mantis uh he was kind of just walking
through the movies for me yeah it wasn't
really much of a presence overall or
that I was like it was more like us more
like I felt like Chris Pratt showed up
to play
to dress up as Star-Lord for this rather
than I felt like I was with Star-Lord
yeah you know yeah I feel like if they
could have given him maybe just a touch
of that George bailiness like a minute
or two which is like a lot like just
like a minute yeah that's the show like
he is really depressed about not having
Gamora around him give him a true yeah
sort of intimate or vulnerable moment
because he's mostly just going around
and you know coordinating things and
like dealing with people and it's in his
performance like you can tell that he
doesn't seem like he's chipper yeah he
seems a little bit down and he seems a
little bit less energetic and bombastic
than normal yeah um so yeah but that's
why I was craving just to shine a little
bit more of a light on it because that
works for like subtlety but something
like this I'm like no I I didn't I felt
like I needed that scene just so that
emotional Beats at the end of ah they
brought the joy of Christmas here
they're together now even though he's
sad you know like he doesn't even really
have a line about that yeah and I mean
honestly and and not to again it's not a
big deal because it also at the length
that this is and what kind of special
dishes shooting for you know you can't I
guess you don't want to go super long or
eventually you're just making a movie
but uh but yeah I couldn't use a little
bit of that and maybe just to I
personally maybe wanted a little bit
more
you know it's like I felt like with the
wrap up at the end between him and
mantis that brought some catharsis and
especially spending so much time with
her and Drax like you said I really
liked the way that their Dynamic got to
shine I I would have maybe at the end
liked maybe just a to me it would have
been like a beat as maybe on Rocket
Groot you don't need it as much but I
wanted to feel maybe more of that real
team Christmas catharsis like it had a
big like I know the point is to cheer up
Peter but I wanted to feel like it had a
big impact on everybody and it feels
like you know rock rocket is there you
know he gets he gets his gift it's a fun
moment he like there's certainly aspects
of it but I would have liked maybe just
a little more of that heart spell
because rocket is also a character with
a pretty harsh past and and you know
some anguish in his
General makeup yeah well I I feel like
utilizing the special uh what was like
because I feel like the point was mainly
to
you know like you get to highlight
mantis more yeah and
it's because this was this was her she
like if I were to pinpoint a star of the
special to her yeah yeah draxes her back
up yeah Drax is the main supporting
character yeah she's pumped Clement type
was turtle and she's great yeah she's
amazing in here like she was so funny
yeah she was she was hilarious and I
love some of the comedy bits too like I
love the the horror comedy moments of
when she's like hopping on wall like
when you when you hop into Kevin Bacon's
perspective of how he must be of how
he's experiencing this yeah like these
monsters are coming after me it was
funny it was really really funny
um and uh yeah I mean uh yeah for me I I
can't wait I do get what you're saying I
didn't find myself really this this to
me I was looking at the whole picture of
like everything from what the Guardians
of the Galaxy movies are and then the
iron shorts and then this yeah knowing
that Rocket's gonna have such a
substantial thing to go on in Guardians
three apparently
um with uh you know you see baby rocket
in there and stuff so I'm like all right
yeah I I get it like this is gonna serve
Us in between and what I thought this
special really needed was a little bit
more of that enhancement for the
the goal of why they want to cheer up
Peter that much you know which I get was
more linked to the memory of what went
wrong with
of how they view what went wrong with
Christmas so that's why I'm saying like
you don't have to have it be in a bad
mood you don't have to turn them into
like screws yeah like I hate Christmas
because that's not the reality of the
situation otherwise the twist wouldn't
make sense but the whole nice
heartwarming part with yondu which I
thought was another great uh thing to to
include in here because it reminds you
of that the the the nuances of their
relationship was that yondu wasn't
always just an abusive hard ass guy you
know that he did really love Peter and
did view him as his son and especially
since the last time we were with yondu
was in Guardians 2 which was like the
one of the biggest talks was yeah and so
I like that when you check in with here
it brings you back to that version of
yondu at the end versus just leaving you
off with them like messed up memory yeah
yeah absolutely and I feel like it's one
of those things where where the ass like
you know any drawback brought on by the
slightness it's also a big asset because
this is so good it earnestly doing what
it's doing and I liked how Earnest it
was like I feel like especially you know
like Marvel movies aren't averse to
earnesty but there's you know a lot of
humor and stuff that we gotta do and
everything and I thought this did really
nicely to do that but also just like I
loved the Christmas like when he's
walking through and they're turning on
all the different lights it was like
truly dazzling and spectacular you know
in a just a a blend of as things I never
thought I'd have I would be able to
think about where it's like it's Marvel
scale Christmas cheer yeah yeah you know
and I loved having uh that must have
been the old 97s you know as the band
and you know having this musical element
because you know James Gunn is obviously
going to bring his playlist of songs to
have like an actual that brought me back
to like the again having like that 70s
80s sort of Animation yeah but then also
having that variety show like so many
great Christmas comedy specials and just
various Christmas specials have like a a
music component of like people actually
playing on screen I felt like there's a
grinch Miss influence in here sure yeah
um yeah definitely and yeah I thought
this was a really if it was overall
really fun there was something else for
sure that I wanted to quickly pinpoint I
like crackling a lot that's not what I
was going to say but I like Craig learn
a lot in here yeah
um getting to see that really endearing
side to him too
and uh because Cosmo I hope has more
screen time in gardens three whole
monologues worth
in that Eastern European accent
that's a nice Easter egg with game when
her soldiers arm after infinity War I
thought I thought there was going to be
a post credits Bucky like
wandering around perplexed
[Music]
dismayed but that I like that bit at the
end with them decorating Groot and all
that stuff that was that was a nice
little like it was a nice little comic
strip like I do like that that also like
it it does have the feel of of a cartoon
or a comic strip well what I was gonna
okay I remember I was gonna say was that
it uh
I feel like I would have had this
assertion even if I didn't know what the
James gun I don't remember the word for
word what he was said but it was
something along the lines of how he had
an idea and he kind of wrote the first
draft and he wrote like the outline and
like uh uh really fast it was and he
wrote the script really fast and not in
a way that was rushed it just sort of
like came down and I like scripts I do
like it when something feel has that
Flair of it feels spontaneous and fresh
and exciting you feel like they kind of
cooked it up and uh and and and it has
it it kind of that Vibe kind of carries
through here in a in a positive way
because it's there's one thing when
something is rushed versus something
that just was done fast and spontaneous
and I and I like the vibe that I thought
that resonated over here the whole time
too it's like when they're giving each
other the handmade gifts it's it's like
receiving a handmade gift you're like
this might not be like perfectly
symmetrical but it has it's all the
better for it almost you know yeah it
has the cheer and it has like you said I
think spontane uh spontaneous
spontaneity is a good word because it
does feel that way and it has a
lightness of Step that I think is yeah
helped Along by that you know that bolt
of inspiration sort of uh momentum and
that nice little Whimsy and I and to me
in in weird ways just from knowing when
you see like this feels different from
the Guardians of the Galaxy movies this
feels different from James Gunn Suicide
Squad this feels different from
peacemakers you know yeah so when you
see like the versatility there even
though I know James come with DC is
going to be uh you know CEO producer
he's not gonna be directing all them you
know it's just to know that he's got a a
knack for versatility oh yeah is that
because this doesn't feel that like we
just we watched a lot of Peacemaker like
this year was it this year no last year
last year yeah uh was last year
I don't remember I think so it goes last
year I don't remember uh it might have
been might have been early in the year I
don't remember
um but uh yeah when did Peacemaker come
out again I want to say it was like
August last year or something yeah maybe
but um your guess is is quite literally
as good as mine uh but not I I that's
one thing I really liked about it well
and this is it like it's certainly James
Gunn but arguably it's the furthest for
what you would automatically associate
with James gun which I I do appreciate
him for yeah because it's not like a
reverend or I mean it's it's not crude
yeah I mean nebula says [ __ ] at one
point but that's about it you know oh
really I didn't even catch up oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah she says it like
right to the camera oh I don't remember
that but yeah anyway but guys I like
that we got the Cradle stroke because uh
Dave Bautista has been Fan cast as God
of War many times oh absolutely so I
think that would be a it would be great
casting
would be amazing casting craters uh so
yeah anyway what did you guys think
about the holiday special did you guys
really enjoy it give it like uh for what
it is or give it like a solid
8.5 out of 10.
damn hey you know I'll go eight eight
eight eight and a half somewhere in
there I feel like that's a nice little
spot yeah yeah well
with that
um leave your thoughts down below you
can check us on patreon and hey let's do
a
looking at your profile pic you're
perfect to shop for this a
you got pizza the dog
and Kate Bish Haley Steinfeld got that
[ __ ] over on your profile pic so you're
a Marvel fan that's for sure we got
Cosmo the dog in here we are doing a
Guardians at the Galaxy holiday special
so you know what I wanted to say to you
Happy Thanksgiving Gabe I am so happy
that you are with us because your
support
affects me greatly it's me personally it
I was on the verge of losing where I
live
but because of your support
I was able to keep persevering that's a
true story I was telling this guy over
here that I'm about to lose it all man
about to file bankruptcy
but Gabe to chose him John was like you
don't need to file bankruptcy you're
fine financially and I'm like no I'm
gonna do it it's the next step in my
life I just don't think it's necessary I
gotta go bankrupt okay he's like why
would you ever choose to go bankrupt and
then I saw your pledge come in Gabe and
then I said you know what Gabe
because of your pledge it reminds me
there's no need to sabotage everything
so Gabe you taught me a very important
lesson
that if you don't need to go bankrupt
when you're financially fine don't do it
because
I think everyone who's gone bankrupt is
because of that I wouldn't know
the self-sabotage man but I had imagined
that
it's probably just some choice that
they've made on their own and uh not any
other circumstances no no one's no one's
pushed to that point
yeah I don't see why they would unless
there's just negligence and laziness
exactly
um and pure incompetence yeah I can't
imagine any other real reason why want
and disregard
yeah it's just probably bad work ethic
amazing
uh so but that's not me anymore because
you taught me that Gabe's pledge came in
I said
I said that's it
I'm gonna I'm gonna get my life together
I'm gonna to choose to get my life
together all right exercising started
going to therapy
my therapist was even like
you mean you're here because of some
person named Gabe who pledged to your
patreon said that's right when I saw
that notification Bell come in I said
I'm gonna get my [ __ ] together for Gabe
like shouldn't you do that for for
yourself not just for this random person
I said screw you I'm getting another
therapist
five therapists later I'm officially not
going to therapy anymore because I just
don't agree with what they have to say
see that's good that's that's staying
true to yourself and you inspired that
Gabe I mean hey I if I'm not gonna hear
what I want to hear then what's the
point of going why would I pay this
person to help me if they're not going
to a firm racket the way I think
so
Merry Christmas